car alors moi quelqu'un dont on a
beaucoup parlé cette semaine c'est
djamel alors tout le monde en parle
personne n'en sait rien alors on a
demandé un ami à lui qui s'appellera
liddell candilis de venir nous en parler
voici khalid al candélie
oui bonsoir c'est tout le monde a lancé
38 ans vous êtes un ami djamel vous êtes
connus où et comment diamal j'ai connu
une petite dizaine d'années ouais donc
il avait il avait 13 ans à peu près et
donc j'ai connu à trappes dans sa cité
attrape que j'étais intervenu parce
qu'il ya un petit problème
j'étais intervenu pour servir de
médiateur possible d'arranger les choses
oui c'est ça c'est augustin ex champion
de kick-boxing à la retraite alors
presse de président d'une association
pour l'insertion vous occuper aussi du
téléthon banlieue avec france 2 vous
êtes médiateur médiateur national la
jeunesse consultant à la croix rouge
enfin vous êtes tout ce qu'on appelle un
grand frère quoi voilà voilà ça tout ça
j'irai tout ça c'est des choses les
mêmes choses oui c'est en plus mais mais
sinon je suis moi même dans le domaine
audiovisuel
voilà ouais alors vous êtes quelqu'un
d'assez respecter ça qu'on vous a
demandé de devenir d'autant plus que
vous avez été mêlée malgré vous dimanche
dernier à la faire ce qu'on peut appeler
la sphère jamel donc on va voir d'abord
un petit peu de quoi il retourne ensuite
on va voir votre implication dans la
sphère et puis une tentative
d'explication
quand je raconte pour les nos amis
téléspectateurs qui sont pas
obligatoirement au courant de toute la
sphère samedi 1er janvier
djamel va une soirée maghreb à bercy au
popb 8000 personnes
il monte sur scène il souhaite la bonne
année il s'en va vers 23h15 dans l'or
lui c'est une mercedes mais ces 4 4 puis
c'est un style c'est le cas rue et alors
là il ya eu un incident avec les avec
les forces de l'ordre alors la version
de jamel c'est qu'il a été tabassé un
coup de talkie walkie disait son
assistante
la version de la police c'est qu'il a eu
un comportement agressif
voilà pour la faire bon alors vous le
dimanche 2 vous allez à l'hôpital
saint-antoine pour le raisonner et vous
avez une altercation d'abord avec nadia
donc l'assistante de djamel celle qui a
déclaré qu'il avait été battu à coups de
talkie walkie
et puis aussi vous avez été frappé et
mordue et mordue par le garde du corps
de jamel qui n'est autre que le frère de
son assistante
nadia et c'est presque ça non mais dites
si je me suis trompé nous avait déposé
une plainte au commissariat du 12ème tu
peux te tromper vers la fin je veux
faire la violence et c'est à dire c'est
à dire qu'effectivement j'ai j'ai vu
cette image terrible est horrible de
djamel je dirais par terre à la
télévision donc j'ai tout de suite je me
suis tout de suite rendu à l'hôpital
effectivement je me suis retrouvé
d'abord dans un premier temps confrontés
à comment dire aux frères de
l'assistante nadia mourine qui ont - qui
m'a demandé pourquoi j'étais venu à
rejeter venu dans un double but c'est un
premier but c'était de ça de connaître
l'état de santé de jamel et d'un second
but essaie de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé pour évasion voir si on peut
apaiser les choses parce que je trouvais
que ça prenait l'ampleur trop importante
ce discours là il a été très très bien
accepté par l'anc de jamel qui lui si
vous voulez que les choses s'arrangent
il était très mal acceptée par par
l'entourage tant que nadia maureen qui
elle voulait que ça s'envenime puisque à
la base elle était un petit peu à la
base de stars et à partir de là comme il
connaissait tous ne connaissent assez
bien quand même donc
ils ont voulu m'interdire entre la
chambre de jamal donc j'ai demandé à ce
que ces biens jamel qui l'interdisait on
m'a dit non
le garde du corps en question a fini par
m'avouer que c'était nadia maureen et
puis et puis comme il était un peu gêné
de maths et relire la chambre un moment
bon un moment il la seule chose qu'il a
trouvé faire c'est de se jeter sur moi
et puis de m'accrocher comme un pitbull
jusqu'à son nom est d'accepter des
pitbulls aussi on m'a craché comme un
pitbull et de ça vous avez là voilà
c'est un peu maquillée mais est donc et
de et de mordre à 100 bon ça s'est un
peu rétablie et maintenant mais le jour
même j'étais quand même affreux mais
j'aurais pu vous arracher le manceau
basse esquissé ce qu'ils cherchaient ce
que c'était la seule façon bon parce que
il ya eu déjà un premier une première
tentative j'ai remis à sa place
rapidement
en lisant là je ne suis pas venu ici
pour me donner en spectacle devant un
hôpital il ya comment dire il ya des
médecins il y avait mal avec les malades
voyez des médecins il ya des malades
dans le couloir scam et puis avec des
enfants donc c'est pas le petit palais
le et s'il y avait vraiment quelque
chose à faire et aucun problème des
coups de poing et de coups de pieds ça
fait 30 ans que j'en donne ça ne mange
pas à nous d'en donner dans ni d'en
prendre
donc on pouvait le faire à un autre
moment voilà et puis bon et puis après
cela pourrait effectivement comme mon
état le médecin sur place on m'indique
fallait d'urgence était aux urgences et
puis après bon c'était parti quand vous
alliez en fait pour arranger les choses
et vous êtes fait mordre
je suis fille m'a alors là dessus c'est
vrai que là dessus djamel pour moi il
n'avait rien à voir là dedans puisque
après après tout ça pour aller très très
vite
il m'a appelé il m'a appelé pour me dire
pour s'excuser de ce qui s'est passé
qu'il en était désolé tout ça et c'est
vrai que quand j'ai discuté avec lui il
judith c'est jamal vu ce que tu es
aujourd'hui je te connais très bien il
faut pas qu'on te donne l'image que tu
n'as pas parce que quelqu'un jamel c'est
quelqu'un de superbes
c'était un adorable c'est un gamin issu
des quartiers qui a commandé à qui a qui
a mangé de la vache enragée pour arriver
là où d'arrivée moi je les ai connus
quand il avait 13 ans et c'est surtout
quelqu'un qui ne méritent pas l'image
qu'on veut lui donner aujourd'hui et qui
ne mérite pas l'entourage qu'il a
aujourd'hui
et ce qui est ce qui est incroyable
c'est que depuis 10 mois ça c'est son
papa qui me l'a dit parce qu'il
m'appelait jour puisque son papa aussi
les gêner parce que justement comme j'ai
porté plainte
je dirais j'ai presque porter plainte
par rapport à lui pour lui rendre
service et lui et parce que je voulais
montrer l'exemple justement alors rallye
de jamel a été entendu nadia sur
l'assistante a été entendu sa soeur
enfin la serbe nadja fatima le frère de
jamel karim soit entendu par la police
des polices par dgs et déjà été rattrapé
un feu rouge c'est ce qui dit il a été
sorti du véhicule et le policier lui a
fait une clé à son à son bras handicapé
il était frappé à la tête à coups de
matraque au ventre il est tombé sur le
sol alors là où il ya quelque chose de
pas très clair c'est qu'en fait nadia
disais que c'était un coup talkie walkie
des coûts talkie walkie sur la nuque et
lui a déclaré que c'était un coup de
matraque dans le ventre donc même la
faire et pas très très clair parce qu'on
sait pas vraiment ce qui s'est passé en
fait ce soir là au moins vous vous les
ayant approché et a approché l'entourage
de djamel de plus près peut-être vous
connaissez mieux l'histoire c'est à dire
que bon c'est vrai que cette histoire
lll et elle est mal partie elle est mal
parti et puis après via ma il n'a pas
besoin de publicité la plus hostile à
cette publicité il est archi connus et
pour moi ce qui est important c'est que
ce gamin là je veux pas qu'on grille
parce que au niveau des quartiers c'est
quelqu'un qui ait connus reconnus
respectés
je vous donne juste une petite anecdote
des petits gamins des petits gamins dans
le quartier maintenant ils ont le look
jamel c'est à dire qu'ils mettent la
main dans la poche à la main elle est
handicapée et comme d'incroyables donc
donc à partir de là
torchlight laissez nous bien il marche
il y en a marre que cette zone est et on
peux pas alors quand j'ai eu jamal je
lui ai expliqué ce que tu sais djamel si
les flics pendant les policiers
d'arrêter et pas de problème il tarde
est même si tu trouves qui tombe qui
tombe peut-être mal parler ils te
demandent d'arrêter tu t'arrêtes il
demande de donner tes pape et tu donnes
tes papiers et insultes tu encaisses ils
disent n'importe quoi tu encaisses mais
après des quêteurs n'était pas pieds tu
fermes ta voiture tu prends direction le
procureur de la république où tu prends
direction la préfecture de police et y
dépose plainte et parce que tu
t'appelles djamel on sera obligé de
prendre ta place parce qu on saura que
s'ils seront là prend pas communiqué
dessus et quand tu auras peut déposer sa
plainte
là tu peux communiquer dire voilà moi
jamel debbouze issus des quartiers
je suis un citoyen comme tout le monde
et j'ai déposé plainte parce que je j'ai
trouvé comme un mal très bien sûr et je
veux montrer l'exemple à tous les gamins
hélas est un bon exemple et c'est ce
côté là si c'est cela que je voulais
m'excuser mais également bien évidemment
la sphère est pas montré avec l'accident
nucléaire le lia le policier qui a dit
que jamais de gesticuler dans tous les
sens pour fêter ça tout le temps mais
que s'il avait vu sur scène ils
verraient que c'est naturel chez lui de
gesticuler dans tous les ans alors ils
lui ont donc ils ont vu que c'est pas
qu'il était pareil mais maintenant ils
cherchent à emmerder bien entendu ils
disent que il n'a pas son père mais en
fait ce permis est caduc que son
véhicule ait pas équipés pour son
handicap
voilà donc c'est vrai que maintenant ils
vont l'emmerdé de toute façon c'est pour
cette raison que je dirais pour pour
l'entourage mois de mai le plus beau
témoins ce que j'ai vu c'était le
tournage du papa de jamel il m'a il m'a
appelé parce que il m'a dit il mais dit
écoute parce que bon jamal voulait que
je retire ma plainte et jeu et je lui
expliqué que c'était pour son intérêt à
lui
moi j'irai c'est pas un bon c'est pas un
problème si j'ai assez pas une morsure
qui va me faire quelque chose de plus
mais c'est le principe puisque je suis
venu pour lui montrer pour qu'il montre
l'exemple à moins de montrer l'exemple
citoyens jamais porté plainte de ma vie
l'attaquant j'espère qu'ils veulent
comprendre
j'espère mais ce qui est dommage c'est
que mon par rapport par exemple par
rapport à son papa aimé dit écoute
khalid je sais que jamel c'est ton petit
frère et je sais que tu le feras jamais
de mal mais c'est vrai que actuellement
depuis dizaine de mois depuis qu'il a ce
nouvel entourage
ça passe à pas sa part très mal là je
suis vraiment très content parce que je
suis assis à côté de laetitia comme
diamanti ça j'ai vu quand j'étais gamine
très bien ça va passer cette question
alors laetitia vous qui connaissez
khalid qui connaissait djamel vous
pensez quoi de cette affaire j'étais pas
là nous que je vais pas je sais pas
personne peut raconter ce qui s'est
passé puisque la version évidemment sont
pas les mêmes mais sur le fond parce
qu'il est connu aussi dans sa chair de
cesser ses pareils quoi céder parce
qu'il s'appelle jamel debbouze si ça
plait je suis femme n'importe quoi on
connaît pas il est pas connue je pense
pas qu'on aurait fait tout un fromage et
tout donc c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'effervescence autour de cette histoire
et je pense que tout ce qu'a dit très
vite c'est vrai quoi c'est dis pas de
bêtises comme moi je le connais depuis
petit 1 comme il est
et puis c'est quelqu'un de gentil et qui
fait beaucoup pour les autres donc et
jamel est un garçon extraordinaire moi
je l'avais vu deux jours avant que ce
donc se soit passée cette histoire et
c'est un garçon qui est plein de vie
c'est un garçon qui est gentil et qui
qui aiment les autres et qui là pour
faire rire
à la base c'est ce que j'ai fait rire à
la base on air on est des artistes qu'on
soit chanteur acteur comique ou quoi que
ce soit on est là pour faire du bien aux
gens et pour sortir les gens de leur
quotidien
dès qu'il nous arrive un tout petit
dérapage tout le monde s'acharne sur
nous et c'est automatiquement on nous
donne une image qui n'est pas la nôtre
et on est obligé de on peut pas trop se
défendre non plus c'est pour ça qu'on
parle pas parce que plus on en parle et
plus ça remue et plus on s'en sort pas
quoi donc on fait rien on peut rajouter
aussi que curieusement dans le même
temps quelqu'un devait être sur les
côtes bretonnes
il n'y était pas dans son dans le temps
imparti
pendant ce temps à y avait des jeunes
gens de confessions différentes silk qui
sont partis pour voir s'il mazuch sur l'
écoute tout à fait donc du bien
rebondir pour rebondir un petit peu sur
richard bohringer c'est que je dirais
nous notre combat si vous parlez des
confrères nous donne combat nous notre
combat un petit peu c'est d'essayer
je dirais d'honorer le sacrifice de nos
parents nos parents ils sont venus dans
ce pays pour nous apporter ce qu'il
pouvait pas nous pas d'apporter mon pays
d'origine
ils ont laissé leur santé ils ont cessé
leur jeunesse pour nous c'est pas pour
qu'aujourd'hui on voit leurs enfants
dans les faits divers c'est tout moi
c'est ça le social de combien
maintenant on va passer à kad et olivier
on a fait petite promo tout à l'heure on
va faire grosse promo main sur bon
d'accord allons-y ses peurs ses
instruments vois mon jingles te plaît
non je vais qu'on regarde pour changer
un peu les idées quand même parce que
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt grave ce qu'on
vient de dire même si c'est important de
le dire mais c'est vrai que cette image
est pas mal quand même
mais de là quand même ce que vous êtes
juive il est arabe et kader mal élu je
suis musulman ouais mais ça marche
les marocains d'origine tous les deux
1 et tous les états y vit la cour
chanter la sanction de l'attention que
mourir à on se produit tous les samedis
soir au champ de courcouronnes dans le
rayon vaisselle biologique bercy et
samantha bien va justement je dois je
dis si je suppute baker chez michou